[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well,
greetings everyone.
First of all, in terms
of the reading list,
today we're going to
finish the two, three
things I deliberately didn't
do at the end of the lecture
on firms and production sets,
which was largely Kreps,
but with plenty of stuff added.
I should say the stuff that's
added is largely anticipating
an application we got
to at the end, which
is the impact of tariffs and
so on, on economic welfare.
So you'll have the tools
at the time we get there,
although we will also
provide some reminders.
The second thing is,
although it's not starred,
there are these things about--
other things on the
reading list, which are not
starred in this case, about
the great Japanese earthquake.
And that's-- I'm going to
talk about that momentarily,
but I know everyone's
quite busy,
and there's plenty of
required things to do.
But if you get a chance, I'm
sure you actually would enjoy
taking a look at that article.
Today, the main thing I want
to draw your attention to
is decision making under
uncertainty and also
linear programs.
And that material
is largely coming
from Nicholson and
Schneider, although it
does have some material
that was moved relative
to earlier years.
As you will see,
this Medville, which
is short for the medieval
village economy--
several of the slides
today have material
on that from that book,
which you therefore
might find helpful.
In terms of the study guide,
we have some questions here.
And let me try
something a bit new--
but nevertheless, let me try.
Armando, could you take
a crack at this one--
define increasing, decreasing,
and constant returns
to scale and production?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so first,
constant return to scale
means that if you
double the inputs,
you get double the outputs.
Increasing means that efficiency
increases as we scale it up,
so if you double
the inputs, you get
more than double the outputs.
And decreasing is that
if you double the inputs,
you would get less than double.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, that's fair.
That's a pretty good answer.
We can define these
things in various ways.
They're all equivalent
with one another.
The way you did it is fine.
And in some respects,
the definitions
are the reverse of
what you would expect.
Decreasing returns to scales
means that if you pick any--
if you pick zero and any
other point in the production
possibilities set, and then
pick alpha between 0 and 1,
that that point is also
in the production set.
I say it's weird,
because decreasing--
you're actually
scaling back as opposed
to doubling and moving forward,
but it's the same definition
because you do
get that curvature
in the production set, and
likewise for increasing
returns.
So thank you, that's good.
All right, I marked
a few of these.
We don't have to do all of them.
How would you prove
that maximized profits
are homogeneous of
degree 1 in prices p?
Caleb, if I'm saying
your name correctly--
Aulins?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sorry,
what was the question?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Prove
that maximized profits
are homogeneous of
degree 1 and prices p.
How would you go
about proving that?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Do you recall
what homogeneous of degree 1
means?
AUDIENCE: No.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK, so
homogeneous of degree 1
means that if you increase every
element of the price factor
by a constant that
maximized profits,
increased by that same constant.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Do
you feel comfortable
taking a crack at
the rest of this?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure
what the answer is.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK,
all right, that's fine.
Wang Ping-- and correct me if
I'm saying your names wrong.
I'm sure I am.
AUDIENCE: In the future,
you can just call me Andy.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Andy, OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's the
A in your middle initial.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
OK, so let's see.
Do you want to try
the same question?
AUDIENCE: Sure,
yeah, so homogeneity
means basically, if
we double the prices,
then we also double the profit.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Right.
AUDIENCE: Right, so I believe
that profit function is
equal to-- is p.z, where z
is the production vector.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And so if we double
the price p, if we double the--
if we double the
production, so if we
maintain the same
production vector,
z, then we can guarantee that
we at least double the profits.
But if we were
able to do better,
then we could then
halve the prices again
and obtain a better--
basically, a better production
for the original price level.
And so basically, the optimal
profits at the doubled prices
must exactly equal twice the
value at the regular prices.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Right, I think
that's the correct answer.
The way I like to think
about it is if we--
graphically, if we were doubling
the price of every component
of the price vector,
p, then we're
not changing the slope
of those isoprofit lines.
And so the tangency with
the production possibilities
frontier would be
the same point.
And that's why the z,
as in p.z is not moving.
Great, thank you.
And let's try just one more.
What is the definition
of an isoquant?
So Ke Qiu--
AUDIENCE: I think the
definition of isoquant
is like, there was a
set of input boundaries
which, given the
productivity, they
will output the same
level of output y--
all input bounders which produce
the same level of output.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yes that's correct.
Great, thank you.
OK, so I was too ambitious and
I marked off too many of these.
As I said, I sort
of choose at random.
In this case, this morning,
I just marked a few of them.
Take a look at the other ones.
As always, these review
questions are for your benefit,
for the class.
I'm only calling on you
now instead of just taking
volunteers because I
like class participation,
and it's just a reminder to try
to keep up rather than having
to make up lost ground
later, when you're studying
for the midterm or something.
If you keep up with the
class, you'll be fine.
OK, so let me go to lecture
4 and talk a little bit
about three related
examples of production
I featured in the lecture,
the example of trade.
But here are some
others that actually
do relate to what we will get
to at the end of lecture 5
as well.
First off, I want to talk about
Leontief input-output matrices.
So Leontief's view of
the economy's production
possibilities was interesting,
albeit a bit simple.
Suppose there are three sectors,
for example, as in this matrix.
You have a sector representing
raw materials, which
could be agriculture,
or mining, and so on,
and a sector
representing services,
which would be retailing,
advertising, transportation,
lawyers, real estate agents,
and financial services--
could go on and on.
And manufacturing, which I guess
is pretty self explanatory--
this entire page
of lecture is just
meant to be representative.
Obviously, you can have
many particular rows,
depending on your
willingness to disaggregate
further and further into
in more and more detail.
So this matrix, what it's
saying is the motivation
for this is you have
some final demand,
and how much would
you need to produce
to satisfy the final demand?
You could have final
demand for services,
but the problem with that is
that's the final demand, not
all the intermediate demands.
Services are in turn
used in other sectors.
And in fact, the
column here represents
that to produce $1
worth of services--
services are used in other
sectors, as in this row.
Services show up in
producing raw materials,
services show up in
producing services
because of that
aggregation problem,
and get used in manufacturing.
Likewise, if you
go down the column,
to produce $1 worth
of services, you
need $0.04 worth
of raw materials,
$0.03 worth of services, and
$0.01 worth of manufacturing.
So you can see,
its input-output--
these are both in some
sense direct outputs,
but also indirect inputs
into other sectors.
This is a version, by
the way, of the question
having to do with aggregation.
Last time, we had a slide
showing two goods, x and y,
I think--
or was it Y1 and Y2.
And one used Y1 as
an input and used Y2,
and the other industry used
Y2 as an input to produce Y1.
That was decreasing returns.
This is linear constant
returns, because everything here
is linear, but it is the same
idea of inputs and outputs.
So we take this information
in the input-output matrix
and summarize it in a
matrix A, and here we're
just reproducing these row
column elements exactly.
OK, so the problem is we have
final demands, which are given,
which is a three
dimensional column vector.
And it tells us how
much we're going
to need to end up delivering
either to consumers
or for exports, of
raw material services
and manufactured
goods, in that order.
So if we think about
these equations here,
we want to produce x.
And then we want to
figure out how much
to produce if we want to meet
the final demands of 400, 200,
and 600.
But in addition to that,
some of that output
gets used in turn as
inputs, and is not
available for consumer
and export demands.
So the key equation here would
be, if we need to produce x,
but we lose a times x
because some of that output
gets used as
inputs, then we have
to produce i minus a times X.
I is the identity matrix here.
So it just picks up the same--
it is 1 on the diagonal
and 0 on the off diagonal.
So for example, ia would
just give you x back,
as if you didn't have
to use things as inputs.
Ax, that we've been going
through here, gives you--
if you're going to produce
x, how much of that
x gets used up in producing
services, raw materials,
and manufacturing?
And what's left, I minus a times
x, should just equal demand.
So this is a linear equation in
the control variables, namely
x.
And also, demands are given.
Although to
anticipate a bit, you
might think there's some
trade off in demands,
or maybe some linear
combination of demands is fine,
not just specific numbers.
And then you could
imagine maximizing demand,
but in any event subject
to this constraint.
Here, it's simpler.
We're just given
the demands, and we
have to produce x in such a
way as to meet the demand.
So this is a linear system
of linear equations.
And if you remember a
little matrix algebra,
all we need to do is to invert
this matrix, in minus a,
which eliminates
it on both sides--
on the left hand side, and puts
it on to the right hand side.
So the x solution we want
is i minus a times dx.
So I going to say in this
case, you can go back up
and realize that
this was 0.2, so i--
1 minus 0.2 is 0.98, and so on.
Nothing gets subtracted
on the off diagonal,
because i is 0 there.
So as long as this is what
we would call a non singular
matrix, that the
rows and columns are
independent of each other, one
is not a multiplicative factor
of any of the other two,
then this inverse exists
and we can solve the problem.
And you can see although it
should be intuitive by now
that they need to produce more
than the 400 of raw materials.
They need to produce 449.
Actually, these were denoted
in billions, and likewise,
how much more of each relative
to the exogenously given demand
actually depends in a pretty
complicated way on that matrix
A, in the following sense.
To produce a unit
of services, one
has to take into account
the inputs of manufacturing
and raw materials.
But to produce manufacturing
and raw materials,
one has to take into account
that they too utilize services,
and so on.
And actually, you
can kind of keep
going back into the matrix.
Another way to write
the system of equations,
actually, to get the
inverse, is to successively
plug-in first approximation,
second approximation,
third approximation as
you take into account
more and more of the
layers of the interaction.
So you could have a sector
which doesn't contribute
much to final demand, but
is crucial as an input
into the other two sectors.
So that sector could
have a high importance,
even though it's not
directly satisfying
the demand of itself.
So then we come to Google, and
in particular their algorithm.
When you type in a keyword,
it pops up in a rank order
the most likely things
that are related
to what you just searched for.
This was invented by
Sergey Brin and Larry Page.
I sometimes wonder if
people's last names are not
predictors of their
eventually careers,
Larry Page being one of
the fathers of PageRank,
but anyway, that algorithm is
really based on the same ideas
that underlie Leontief's ranking
of industries, which is you
Google up something,
and it may be
that there's an article
that you might not
have thought to be the
most important one,
because it may not seem to
answer the question directly.
But in fact, it's
the key article
that started it all, that
has been cited and used
by other things that are more
directly linked to the Google
item that you're searching for.
And this display is not
by sectors of industries,
but just by a network diagram.
You can see these
things directly related
via pathways to things in
the center, these outliers
or clusters.
And then it gets very
thin, but they could end up
being important
because they're related
to things in the interior.
These things are ranked
by distance, actually,
reordered in order
for the diagram
to display the
degree of closeness.
And they-- Page and
those guys actually
cited on Leontief
and output matrix.
And then as a final
example, the Great East
Japanese earthquake--
to remind you, there was an
earthquake, a big one, and then
a subsequence tidal wave.
And actually, the
coastline I think
subsided by a meter, or
some outrageous amount.
And so in came the tidal
wave, doing a lot of damage.
And this is highlighting
the damaged structures.
the headquarters
of firms whose headquarters'
location was destroyed
in the immediate aftermath of
the earthquake and tsunami.
By the way, the Fukushima
nuclear power plant
was right there,
adding to the mix.
So then we move over here.
This is all of the
main island of Japan.
And this is the area that's
highlighted, the small area
here.
And then we ask, as
an input-output sense,
which industries had been
supplying to headquarters which
is not per se just where all
the management is, but like
the primary production facility.
You have inputs supplying to
General Motors, for example,
in Detroit.
You have tire manufacturers
that are linked-- this is Japan.
So we have input suppliers
linked to headquarters,
or intermediate.
And likewise, in principle, it's
not just inputs from upstream,
but outputs downstream.
The disruption here means
you can't produce something
which is in turn supplied
downstream, quote unquote,
to others.
So the first order connection,
as in the PageRank,
are these areas in red.
And now, we've
covered all of Japan,
because there's either an
immediate input supplier
or output purchaser
indirectly damaged
in the sense of the
first degree, again,
that's the primary
area of damage.
This is second degree
damage, A linked to B,
who was hit with C, and so on.
So eventually, as you go in this
case down to the fifth order,
most of Japan was covered.
And in fact, this
Japanese earthquake
caused a drop in national
level GDP of about 1.5%.
It is, though, just
another illustration
of the same mathematics.
So now, with some
trepidation, let
me go to lecture 5
and verify that you
can see this on your screens
as I move through it.
Yes, you can see it right?
So this is decision
making under uncertainty,
and then we'll get back
to some of our techniques,
in particular programming,
linear programming.
So let's suppose
we have a lottery,
and there are little n distinct
prizes, possibly zero, possibly
negative if it takes money away.
So these X's are the amount
of the winnings or losings,
if that even turns
up in the lottery.
There are n possible
things that can happen,
and they happen with
these probabilities
pi, pi1 being the probability
that the gains or losses is
in the order of x1,
pi2 for x2, and so on.
Because it's a lottery,
the probabilities
themselves are not negative.
They're 0 or positive.
And it's a
comprehensive lottery,
choosing over this vector
of possible outcomes,
so the probabilities
add up to 1.
In other words, the lottery is
a well-defined random variable,
with these n distinct
realizations.
And we can call the
expectation of the lottery,
the expected outcome
of the lottery
of the random
variable capital X,
just to be the weighted
average of the outcomes
where the weights are
these probabilities.
So part of this--
these next few slides
have to do with the ideas of
lotteries over discrete items.
Part of the next few
slides are quick reviews
of some basic ideas
and statistics.
Here's a basic idea
from statistics.
If we have a random
variable, capital X,
when we want to talk about its
variability or its variance,
denoted is sigma squared X,
that is just the dispersion of X
around the mean, mu X.
Mu X was defined here
in the previous slide
as the mean squared.
So we square the differences.
If X were equal to its
mean, this would be 0.
The further away
it is, the higher
the squared value would be.
Expectation again
means that we're just
taking weighted averages, with
the weights being these pi I
probabilities.
So this would be the
formal expression.
The variance is
the proxy for risk.
The square root
of the variance is
called the standard deviation.
And if we want to normalize
it so we can interpret
the units of it without
knowing the magnitudes
of the underlying variable,
we divide by its mean.
So the standard deviation
divided by the mean
is called the
coefficient of variation.
What I mean by normalizing
isn't just that we're dividing,
but the reason
for dividing-- you
could well imagine if we
have two random variables
and one is twice the other
one, then all the values
are doubled, and the measure of
the dispersion will go up too.
So if we wanted to
measure variability,
that's kind of independent of
the scale of the underlying
random variable itself.
One more slide on statistics--
so suppose the prize has two
dimensions, X and Y, not just
the winning and losings
of dollars, but maybe
two different commodities.
So a particular
realization or outcome
would be a specification
of both the value of X
and the value of Y Xi,
Yi for realization i.
Realization i happens
with probability pi i,
which is the same as before.
Now, though, we can
define the covariance
between two random
variables, x and y,
to be the expectation of
the product subtracting off
the means.
So X plus its mean uX,
times Y minus its mean uY.
And I didn't write it out,
but you could just sum it up
over the same pi is instead
of writing the expectation
operator.
It tells you whether
the variables x and y
are moving together or moving
in opposite directions.
So for example, when
a high value of X
corresponds with
a high value of Y,
thinking collectively about
these realizations Xi or Yi,
then this covariance
is positive.
And likewise, if a
high x means a low y,
the covariance
would be negative.
You could think about
plotting the Xi, Yi variables
as in a cloud and
trying to figure out
if the cloud is running
on the 45 degree line
or running in the
reverse direction,
from northwest to southeast.
Again, it's useful to normalize,
so we take that covariance
and just divide it by the
product of the variance, called
the correlation.
And correlations are
by construction going
to be between minus 1 and 1.
So again, 0 means no
correlation, 1 means perfect
correlation, positive
direction, n minus 1,
means negative correlation.
So those are the three
statistical review slides,
and we're going to come
back to them momentarily.
They're all defined
for random variables,
but we defined a random
variable by first thinking
about a lottery.
So let's come back
to the lottery.
Here, in fact, the underlying
ingredients are x1 and x2,
but they can only take on
a finite number of values.
These dots represent a discrete
point, and this commodity space
here, the values of x1 and
x2, which are feasible,
this is not a convex space,
because you can easily
find lines between
any two of these dots.
And intermediate points on the
line other than the end point
are not in this consumption set.
So this is a non-convex set.
Back to the lottery
interpretation,
lets call, say, Cs a particular
realization or state or point
in the commodity space--
and capital C. S denotes the
set of all possible states.
It's just counting
up the number of dots
you're seeing on this picture.
So for example, if there are
capital S dots or states,
each state corresponds to
a particular consumption
bundle in R2, and we can
call pi S the probability
of being in state S. So we could
have a lottery over this space.
If we define those lotteries,
a particular lottery
would put a non-negative
probability, perhaps 0,
on any particular state.
And the sum of the probabilities
over all the states
would have to add up to 1.
So that's a particular lottery.
The set of all possible
lottery is the set
of all probabilities pi that
satisfy these two characters
called, call it capital Pi.
It's also called a simplex.
By definition, a
simplex is a set
where each element
is non-negative,
and all the elements
add up to 1.
So a lottery satisfies the
definition of a simplex.
Other things do, too.
OK, so this becomes the
new commodity space, not
the set of underlying
points, but the set
of lotteries on those points.
And likewise, we now
can define preferences
with this squiggly
script inequality
over the set of
possible lotteries.
And what we're going to use
is von Neumann Morgenstern
expected utility,
which is quite natural.
And it's saying, take
a particular point
Cs in that space, take the
underlying utility of it--
which we've been using before.
Take the probability
of that state
and then sum it up over
all possible states
and define this
expected utility.
So these are the underlying
real value numbers
of deterministic utility.
This object over
here on the left
is the expected utility for
a particular lottery pi.
And the idea now is that
all possible lotteries
can be ranked by this
expected utility criterion.
Let's just note in passing
that this expected utility
criterion is linear in
the choice objects, which
are the lotteries.
These u of Cs things become
coefficients, real numbers.
But we're not varying the
underlying commodity points.
So these become fixed numbers.
And the thing that we're
interested in varying
would be the probabilities
that constitute the lottery.
So the objective function is
linear in the probabilities.
There are some criteria we
need to satisfy in order
to rank using expected utility.
What we want to get
at the end of the day
is that a lottery pi is strictly
preferred to a lottery pi
prime, if the expected
utility under pi
is strictly greater than the
expected utility under pi
prime.
In order to do that, we need
three axioms, these three.
The first combines two--
cheating a bit.
Completeness says
that all lotteries can
be ranked and give us a number.
And transitivity, I
think you can see,
is going to be satisfied,
because if A is preferred to B,
lottery pi is preferred
to lottery pi prime,
and pi prime is preferred
to pi double prime.
Under the preference
ordering, we
can map those
preference orderings
into these expected
utility objects,
which are just real numbers
that satisfy transitivity.
So those are intuitive
properties, completeness
and transitivity.
Here's something
called independence.
Take two lotteries of focus,
denoted pi and pi prime,
and say that pi is weakly
preferred under that expected
utility ordering to pi prime.
Then it has to be true that
some alpha weighted lottery--
this is a lottery,
pi is a lottery.
And pi prime is a lottery.
And pi triple prime
is also a lottery.
So now we're taking compound
probabilities, if you like,
when we take the alpha weighted
sum of the lottery pi and pi
prime.
If alpha were, say,
equal to 1, then we're
already given that pi is
weakly preferred to pi prime,
and that would be an equivalent
statement on the right hand
side.
If alpha is less
than 1, however,
then we're putting some weight
on this extraneous third
lottery, pi double prime, and
the notion of independence
means that whatever this
other lottery looks like,
it doesn't matter
for fixed alpha
when it comes to weighting
pi and pi double--
weighting the composite lottery.
Because each one of
these, The second term
in each one of these expressions
is 1 minus alpha times
pi double prime, which is the
same on the left hand side
as it is on the right hand side.
So the ranking is independent
of whatever that term is.
It seems like it
ought to be true,
but it's actually an axiom.
Continuity is similar,
although not identical.
It says if we have three
lotteries pi, pi prime,
pi triple prime, and
they're rank ordered--
pi, preferred to pi prime,
preferred to pi double prime,
then there exist numbers
alpha and beta such
that this weighted
sum of pi and pi
double prime, weighted
by alpha, is strictly
preferred to pi prime,
which is strictly
preferred by the beta weighted
sum of pi and pi double prime.
Now the way to see
this is that it's not
required to be true
for all alpha and beta,
it's only required to be
true for some of them.
So if we were allowed
to set alpha equal to 1,
we would have alpha pi
on the left hand side,
and pi prime would be over here.
We'd have pi
preferred to pi prime,
but that was a given to begin
with, so no new information.
This is saying if
alpha is arbitrarily
close to 1, then that
ought to be true,
and hence the notion
of continuity.
Likewise, on the
right hand side,
if beta were zero, which
it's not allowed to be,
then we'd be just getting
pi double prime here.
And we're already
given that pi prime is
preferred to pi double prime.
The content of it is if beta
is not 0 but very close to 0,
then we should preserve
the rank order.
These are intuitive properties.
They're here only to say
that expected utility may not
be, quote unquote, as general
as you might think when facing
problems of choice
under uncertainty,
although it is very natural.
And these properties are
similar in some respects
to what we did before with
ordinary preference orders.
And with regard to
what we did before,
there was already a
question from one of you
about this, what about
choice under uncertainty?
Now, our measure of utility
becomes cardinal, not
just ordinal.
We are really going to care
about the degree of curvature
in this orange line, which is
mapping the expected utility
outcome as we vary the input x.
So what's going on
in this setup here?
We have income,
say, moving around,
and it has a mean
expected value of x,
and it has a couple of
endpoints-- the lowest value
x0, the highest value x1.
Let's say for simplicity
that's all that's going on,
that the lottery that
creates the random variable
is nothing other than some
weighted average of x0 and x1.
And those weights are such as
to produce exactly this expected
value.
And that's what's being
drawn with this line,
namely expectation of x
is a weighted combination
of x0 and x1.
Given the expectation
of x, we could
ask what the utility would be
for that deterministic value,
and it would be--
we would have to go up here if
they were getting it for sure,
and over here, and
have the utility
of the expectation of x.
That may be a funny
place to start,
because there's a
genuine lottery here,
and you can't get
the mean for sure.
You have to engage
in the lottery
and suffer the randomness
around the mean.
So what is the actual
utility of the lottery?
Well, that can be
achieved in this diagram
by taking a weighted
average of the utility
of the extreme points.
Here's the utility you would
get for the high value, x1.
Here's the utility you
get for the low value, x0.
If you take a weighted
average, you'll
be moving along this line.
You'll actually take this
weighted average here
that also determines the mean,
and go over here and plot
the utility of the outcome.
So this is the expected utility
under the actual lottery,
and it's just the
appropriately weighted average
of the utilities of
the two extremes.
You're with me so far?
So as you can see, if instead
of suffering the lottery,
you gave this decision
maker a deterministic value
with the same utility
level as the utility has
under the lottery, what
would that value be?
That would be right here.
If you started with this
value of x for sure,
and went up to the
orange line, you
would get the utility there.
But that value of x is obviously
a lot lower than the mean.
This is called the
certainty equivalent
value of the lottery.
Let me put it a bit differently.
If you told the
household to choose
between the lottery and
a deterministic value
with a mean less than
the mean of the lottery,
they might choose the
deterministic value
as long as that value is not
less than the risk premium.
Anything here,
they would choose.
Anything over here,
they would not.
Right here, they
would be indifferent.
Now, as I think you can
imagine, if you increase
the curvature of
this function, you're
going to actually be
lowering the expected utility
of the lottery, because
there's more risk associated
with it, in the sense that you
care more about the variance
because your utility
is more curved.
And that's going to change
the certainty equivalent
amount as well.
So from now on, for
much of the class,
we're going to be considering
cardinal rather than ordinal
utility.
What are standard
measures of risk aversion?
There's something
called absolute risk
aversion and another thing
called relative risk aversion.
Absolute risk aversion
has to do with how
your marginal utility is
changing as you change
the reward, the consumption.
And relative risk aversion has
to do with how much utility
is changing as you change
the percentage of wealth
that you have.
I'll spare you the
derivations of all of this,
but I will show you some
example utility functions that
display either
absolute risk aversion
constant or relative risk
aversion on the next slide.
So absolute risk aversion
is your willingness
or not to take up gambles,
like, starting with $100,
add plus or minus 10.
The lottery is from 110 to 90.
The relative risk
aversion has to do
with proportional gambles.
You start with, say, 100 and
then have 10% gains or losses.
That would be the same, but
you could start with 1,000
and have 10% gains and
losses, in which case
you'd be facing a lottery that
moves you from 1,100 to 900.
Under constant relative risk
aversion, all you care about
are those percentage differences
from your initial wealth.
Under absolute risk
aversion, you actually
don't like that new--
if you started with
$1,000 as opposed to $100,
your absolute risk aversion
would actually be going down.
Because of the
curved utility, you
would be thinking about a
lottery around a point that
has less curvature.
Attitudes toward risk do
depend on these functions.
So here are the examples.
This one is constant
absolute risk aversion.
And it's an
exponential function--
looks kind of weird
at first because
of all these negative signs.
Say, well, exponential
is positive-- yes,
so as C goes up,
utility is going down.
What the heck's going on here?
But we put a negative sign
in front of all of this
to correct for that.
So you could take the derivative
and the second derivative
and verify that this function
has constant absolute risk
aversion, and the order of
magnitude is actually a.
Or if you started
down here, we'd
have constant relative
risk aversion,
and you can verify
if you did the math--
u prime u double prime times C
that you would get a number R.
So R is the constant level
of relative risk aversion
under this function.
And we often use these
for different purposes.
They'll show up
in an application
we'll get to in about, I
guess about four lectures.
Let's talk some more about
lotteries and uncertainty.
Actually, we'll now throw
in not just uncertainty
as in states of the
world S, but also time.
So time is evolving from
day 1 to day 2 to day 3.
So from the perspective of your
initial starting point, i0,
you could experience a low
or a high state at date one.
And if you're at date one,
you're still facing risk,
so you could go low
or high from there.
If you went to medium,
then you could go and turn
all over again from
low, medium, to high.
These branches of the
trees with the nodes
reflect every possible
realization and the path
to get there.
From the standpoint
of expected utility,
we would start here, ex ante,
before anything happens at all,
and trace the
probabilities at date one.
You get this or this or this
with certain probabilities,
pi s1, given s0.
But you'd also take
into account day two,
so you take the expectation
of being here or here,
or any of these
intermediate branches.
And finally, you'd have
to add in the day three,
where all these events at the
thinnest branches of the tree
could come to pass.
If there's anything
counterintuitive
about this diagram, it is
that when some things happen,
other things don't happen.
So when you're over
here and move left,
you've eliminated the other
two branches of the tree.
If you took expected
utility from day one onward,
you would just be
taking into account
what's left that could
potentially happen at random.
But this criterion down here
is taking expected utility
as if nothing yet
has happened at all.
So taking into account all
the possible events at day
1, at day 2, and day 3.
So we can immediately
get to a building block
that's crucial to understand
finance and financial markets,
and that's the notion of a
state contingent commodity.
We've already been doing it.
The state contingent
commodity with only one date
would be the probability of
getting a certain wealth payoff
or certain xy combination
of goods and so on.
So what you get depends on the
state, commodity bundle you get
depends on the state.
We call it state contingent.
You get wheat tomorrow if it
rains, but nothing otherwise.
And we imagine you can actually
buy these kinds of contingent
pay off securities in
the financial markets.
However, a much
better way to put
that is any
financial security is
a weighted average,
probabilistic weighted average
over all possible events.
For example, you're an
investor and you bought
in-- someone's lending to you.
And let's imagine they are
never going to default.
Then, you're going to get
that money back for sure,
in which case, it's
not risky anymore,
but that's only because
the event is the same.
Or you could have something
like a stock option,
so that it doesn't come in
to play unless the stock
prices are particularly high
and you execute the option.
So all possible securities
can be represented as linear
combinations of these primitive
Arrow-Debreu securities--
primitive in the sense
that they, building blocks,
only pay off in the event of
one well delineated event, and 0
otherwise.
So when we get to
competitive markets
and how to handle
uncertainty, we'll
come back to these state
contingent commodities.
OK, so let's move to an
application of various
of these things, one lotteries,
two, random variables, three,
diversification of portfolios.
Except in this case,
they're not going
to be trading financial
assets, they're
going to be holding
plots of land.
So the next map I'm
going to show you
is a village of Elford in
Stratfordshire, England,
in 1719, before enclosures.
And shaded in black are the
holdings of Mr. Darlaston.
So here's that village,
Elford, Stratfordshire.
And you have to
look a little close,
but you see these darker
areas, they are shaded in
and represent the
holdings of Mr. Darlaston.
Mr. Darlaston has these
long, narrow strips of land
all over the village,
in all the three fields.
And you could well
think about that
as a portfolio of land
holdings, and in some respects
a portfolio of securities
where in this case,
the holding of land yields a
dividend, which is the harvest.
And you may well surmise
there's some risk here,
or they're weird people,
because why else would they
be doing something like this?
Here's another view of
the village of Laxton.
I should at least tell
you what enclosures are.
Given the way this
land was spread out,
it was impractical
to put fences up
that would mark the division
of the boundary of all
these various strips.
It would have been very
costly to put up the fences
and very difficult to plow.
See the little plows here?
Eventually, enclosures
meant they put--
they divided it up.
They got rid of the
area and divided up
the land in a
different way, just
put fences around the
consolidated pieces of land.
But they didn't do that
for hundreds of years.
They kept this, the scattered
strips, for quite a long time.
OK, so let's move to the data.
The data we have from
this period of time
is from the Bishop
of Winchester.
The church was wealthy
and they kept records.
So this is what
survives, the holdings
of the Bishop of Winchester,
all domains, the crops being
wheat, barley, and oats,
various types of grains.
And these objects denote,
say, the coefficient
of variation, which I've alerted
you is the variance divided
by the mean, standard
deviation divided by the mean.
So this number, say 0.35, is in
the middle of the two others.
Actually, it's a bit
on the lower end.
Even at 0.35, the coefficient
of variation of that magnitude
is a lot of risk.
So let's look at the picture.
If we have those
scattered plots,
those strips, we could plot the
entire distribution of outcomes
with their probabilities.
We could denote the mean,
Us, for scattered plots.
And then we have
disastrous events,
so d represents minimal,
subsistence consumption.
And if you have
these scattered plots
with that coefficient
of variation of 0.35,
then roughly one
in every 12 years
you get a very low yield,
less than 2 times--
2 standard deviations below the
mean, and that's starvation.
And they were starving, we know
this, periodically, every 12
years or so.
Not like clockwork, but
on average every 12 years.
Now, could they have
done something different?
They could have
consolidated the land
and that would have gotten rid
of certain costs and problems.
That would have
moved up the mean,
but you'd be left with more
mass in the tails, and hence
a higher probability of having
a yield that was disastrous.
So the reason that
they're spreading out
the land like that
despite costs has
to do with trying to increase
their expected utility
by putting less
mass in the tails.
Also from the Bishop
of Winchester estates,
which you can hardly see here--
this, believe it or not,
is Southern England.
This is the water down here.
And each one of
these dots represents
an ecclesiastical estate.
And we have the data of the
yields, the harvest yields.
In this case, the
covariate, the correlation--
the statistical concept we
were chatting about earlier--
is what is being plotted
here for villages
that are relatively
near to one another,
and villages that are
relatively far away.
So D means near--
sorry, it's hard
to read the legend.
And so take two
villages pairwise,
look at the correlation
across the two villages.
It's 0.68 on average, picking
villages that are near.
And if you have villages that
are far away one another,
that correlation drops
to something lower,
so the yields are not
moving as much together.
So again, if you were the
Bishop of Winchester, maybe
you chose the location
of your estates
in order to try
to ensure yourself
of having somewhat regular
grain for harvest, for eating,
and to feed the
horses, and so on.
Horses are serious, by the way.
That's the cavalry.
That's the main defense, so
they need it to keep them alive.
OK, then we come to a technique
which we've already been using,
but let's do it from scratch.
And that's called
linear programming.
So this is a linear
programming problem.
X is the control
variable, a vector.
This-- say, column vector--
these constants, coefficient
C, represent a row vector,
so these are weights on
the various x values.
This is a set of constraints,
which is this matrix a times x,
less than or equal to b.
And the x's are non-negative.
So this is notation for a
standard linear program, namely
the objective function.
And the constraint sets just
represent linear combinations
of the control variables x.
I had this in the
back of my head
when we were talking about the
Leontief input-output matrix.
And I said in words, instead of
taking final demand D as given,
maybe it's a weighted
average of demands
that you're trying to
maximize, and you actually
have a choice of
various production modes
to maximize that
weighted average.
So we actually saw an early
version of a linear programming
problem, but the objective
function was not made explicit.
This would be the
consumer choice problem
in a competitive
environment, so where
there's a budget constraint.
So these discrete points,
commodity points C,
denote subscript S
varying over error.
S, states of the world was the
expected utility criterion,
so that's the
objective function.
By choice of lotteries,
so the lotteries
are non-negative
and add up to 1.
To qualify as a lottery,
any given lottery
has to satisfy
those two criteria.
The choice object, as I said--
to belabor it-- is not c of s.
Those are fixed
commodity points.
The choice object are the pis.
And we'll talk about a
budget problem, which
is there are prices p depending
on s-- that is to say,
depending on the underlying
discrete bundle, quite
naturally.
And you've got a
budget in dollars
that you can use
to buy a lottery,
but if the probability
is non-trivial,
it's a number less than
1 and greater than 0,
then you scale the
price of getting
that bundle s back by pi.
In other words, you're kind
of paying the expected price.
If pi s were one, then
you're buying cs for sure
and the price would be ps,
and that would look like
the standard price times
quantity cannot exceed
the budget.
But here, what you're
buying is a lottery,
and the lottery can have
non degenerate elements.
You have to decide how
you would be paying for,
what you would be paying if
you were buying a lottery which
were non degenerate.
And here, you pay as per the
actuarial value of the payoff.
Well, this is another
linear program.
The objective function
is linear in the pis.
The constraint
set is in the pis,
including the budget set,
which is linear in the pis.
So we can solve these things
conceptually and numerically,
recognizing that
it's just a version
of the general notation.
And here's the third.
Suppose we have a firm--
back to production again.
The firm can produce
n possible goods.
The jth good here
has a price, pj.
The firm has a fixed
supply of inputs, which
makes the problem special.
They're not buying these, they
already have them in inventory.
And the technology tells
us how much of input
i is needed to produce good j.
Those are the aijs.
Now here, the natural
objective function
would be the revenue,
price times quantity,
summing over all the j goods.
And you're going
to choose the qjs,
but you can't over
utilize your inputs.
So if the firm is endowed with
input i, then you would say,
how much of input i is
needed to produce good j
times the proposed
quantity of good j,
summing over all goods j.
This would be the
total input requirement
for input i, associated with
producing this vector of goods
q, indexed by j.
And so this is a
linear constraint.
The qs are non-negative.
This is another linear program.
And the last one is what's
called a transportation
problem--
maybe just say it in words.
There are m warehouses,
which are stocked with goods,
and n retail outlets
where goods are sold.
So here, we have geography.
And in particular, in
order to ship the product
from a warehouse to an
outlet, you use up resources.
So this cost, cij, is the
amount of resources you used up,
say, in dollars, to ship the
good from warehouse i to outlet
j.
And then the decision problem
is you're given demands
at all the outlets, and you're
given the amount, initially,
in the warehouses, and you want
to then determine the shipments
from all the
different warehouses
to all the different
potential outlets
to solve the problem, which
minimizes the total cost--
cost from i to j,
warehouses i to outlets j,
and these are the constraints.
The constraint says that
you've got so much in inventory
at warehouse i, so whatever
you're shipping out of i to all
these outlets j, it cannot
exceed that level of inventory,
although it could be less.
And likewise, you have to
meet the demand at outlet j--
So the shipping that's coming
from all possible outlets i
to that particular j cannot
be less than the demand.
So this is another geographic
programming problem.
So we did ordinary production.
We did choice under uncertainty.
We did a spatial
geographic problem.
They're all well known
prototypes in the literature,
and they all use
this common tool,
which is linear programming.
OK, that's all I have for today.